das ist das größte was an ihm mich
angezogen fühlt ist eine
unbeschreibliche tragfläche sein
triebwerk uns ein höhenleitwerk und sein
gesicht
leute ich mein letztes über einen kanal
drüber gegangen und da habe ich mir
gedacht sebastian die leute wollen ein
bisschen abwechslung du kannst nicht
jeden tag eine hilf mir action machen
muss ich aber auch nicht denn im
internet gibt es genug und sein dass man
sich bis an sein lebensende über dinge
lustig machen kann ich heute gültig oder
wenig sagt mir überlegt so ja okay was
machst wenn wir heute bin ich nicht so
wirklich auf die idee gekommen und dann
wurde mir dieses video hin meinen feed
reingepresst altern ich habe mir gedacht
das ist ein zweites video objekt ofili
ich habe sex mit einer boeing 737 800
das und flugzeug die beschreibung das
natürlich passenderweise michelle führt
eine beziehung mit dem flugzeug typ
boeing 737 800 gut wie fühlt sich das an
in einen gegenstand verliebt zu sein wir
haben die 26 jährige berlinerin
getroffen das schauen was die leute aber
bevor wir anfangen muss man dazu sagen
es steht jeder person vollkommen frei
für sich selbst zu entscheiden wo man
sich verlieben möchte womit man schlafen
möchte aber genauso darf ich auch frei
meine meinung dazu äußern
vielleicht die person nicht beleidigen
natürlich scheinbar gibt ihr das
flugzeug liebe zurück nicht von der kfd
flieger selbsterziehung
also es ist übergibt das personal waren
die das vom flieger blick auf das nicht
eben
ich muss noch einer in wien fliegen die
flugzeuge liebe zurückgeben
wie geht das kann ja nicht aktiv und die
gefühle ausdrücken also was man kann
sozusagen eine boeing 737 kann nicht
eigene gefühle ausdrücken
ok
[Musik]
es ist seltsam wie man du bist ja
verliebt in die den eigentlichen flieger
wo menschen drin sitzen
es ist nicht wie voll scheiße wenn sie
tagtäglich so 200 andere männer in
deinem partner sind 800 jeder von denen
aber sie sind in ihren shops die ihre
liebe jeder macht sexuell was ist was
ist auf dem flug passiert dass sie sich
einfach ein flugzeug also das schon mal
gesehen dass eine person mit flug zurück
detailgetreuen nachbau des flugzeuges im
prinzip der ausgleich erst wenn man
einen partner also nicht partnerin kelli
gesehen hat da geht einfach nicht
ja ich will dann vielleicht sagen für
mich ist es nicht dasselbe steigert die
dinge ein steigt wieder auf aber ja
stock people
nein
warum sind so viele alte software nicht
zum besten
[Musik]
kann ich auch nachvollziehen aber ich
mal machen also wenn du hast keine
ahnung was können wir als männer
du hast doch kein bock frauen also
flugzeuge segelflugzeug her da musste
ich im flugzeug von dem kinderkörper
machen
bis 7
[Musik]
also wenn ich mir den psalm tagsüber
oder morgens alleine bin und mit ihnen
kuscheln dann spreche schon ganz normal
wie geht's dir was machst du so was hast
du gemacht hast du hier hätte ich mir
also klein wenn sie sich davon angezogen
für sogar vor allem aber du kannst halt
nicht mit dem wegen reden also es kann
er nicht antworten
also gibt eine antwort das flugzeug
antwortet ja weil mit emotionen
scheinbar also das flugzeug spricht
nicht oder wie das in berlin ich glaube
eher nicht jetzt fast vielleicht kurz
hatte aber mit das flugzeug wird in sie
eine beziehung führt wunsch einfacher
auf geschlechtsverkehr nicht antwortet
dann geht die six hinein einfach deshalb
die fragen so ist das schon sexuell auf
jeden fall stellt man kann dann gelöscht
hatte ich von mir zu sehen war
es ist doch so wie sie wirklich liebt
nichts gemacht es sei deshalb ein foto
im flugzeug wäre das gefühl sie auf sie
abgestimmt auf dem bett aus
dieses flugzeug sieht für mich immer so
einfach los und hatten küche wenn diese
spitze schoss das was sie an ihm ansieht
dass seine und beschreibung die
parkflächen kann man so stehen lassen
oder das müssen wir die kinder aber auch
ein ständiger wenn das alles stimmt wenn
die reifen sind wenn die flügel heißt
dann richtig breit sind um die gehören
dann kommen die checks auch die frage
die es dann ankommt wenn man sonst ein
date als mensch kommt oder mulden 737
kostüme dass jetzt darüber geredet dass
sie was das die mit dem flugzeuge
schlägt nein hat sich nicht gesagt ach
so schlimm weil das video als ich habe
sex mit einer boeing 737 800 der satz
ist eigentlich gar nicht gefallen klick
plakat wirtschaft voll abgeguckt diesem
moment man selbst einfache flug ist klar
aber dazu führen dass sich jeder ecke
gedacht
ich bin von der mutter das war so bei
unserem kleinen ausflug heute in die ein
oder andere etwas speziellere ecke des
internets ich glaube ich bleibe dabei
hilft mir